so 43 seasons of survivor yep when you
first got the gig did you think it was
gonna last as long no no and i i but i
didn't know anything about television i
didn't have a publicist or anything so i
really didn't know how it worked but i
thought that we would for sure get a
second season and then i thought i bet
we'll get a third season before it's
done one of the best stories was friends
was on and thursday night was must-see
tv on nbc and this was back before
streamers so the networks were
everything and you you were in direct
competition with whatever show is on at
your same time on the other network so
if survivor was on at eight o'clock and
friends was on at eight o'clock we were
gonna be competitors we were originally
actually on wednesday and at eight
o'clock on wednesday nothing was on so
the survivor ratings were really big
season two comes up and
kelly call who's still at cbs was in
charge of scheduling and the story he
tells is
you you go to a board and you put all
the shows where you think they should go
and all the executives are going to look
at it and say okay we agree or we don't
agree or wow this is what we're doing
and he said so i'm laying out the entire
thing and you see all the other networks
so there's friends
thursday at 8 o'clock and he goes and i
have this tag that says survivor this
magnetic thing and everybody's waiting
to see where i'm going to put it and i
go put it next to friends
and he said the reaction in the room was
really we're going to leave wednesday
night where we could dominate and go up
against the biggest show in television
history yeah and his quote was when you
have a sledgehammer you gotta use it
survivor's a sledgehammer